welcome Vinnie too buddy yeah you look
really thin thank you and try it yeah I
guess you have to be now you can't put
out a keto cookbook and then like gain
weight right before it comes out no I
got me skinny so I'm like a living proof
of the of the dye I've been doing it for
five years
will you ever fact I'm a fat we were
yeah it was like skinny fat like you
wouldn't be able to tell right no one
would ever like stop you on the street
but if you look back at my before and
after pictures on my Instagram you look
like an athlete now thank you actually I
look back on the old Jersey Shore East
to think I was in shape and then I look
back on and I was like oh like wearing
tank tops like yeah a little bit of a
guy all that partying all that drinking
traveling yeah well plus as you get
older it slows down yeah that happened
for me at like 22 really yeah people
like they still tell me to this day like
when you get older Vinny I'm like no
this is from diet because that that
stops happening at like 22 I got those
Italian bread genetics like so your
signings do bring a lot of people into
because I did there are hundreds yeah
yeah yeah no it's been great I did satin
Island last night at Westchester I
didn't think anyone was gonna come out
to see me in Staten Island cuz like I go
to that mall regularly to buy t-shirts
so just not special yeah but they they
all came out because at the signings you
get a lot of little kids usually I do
I'm in Chippendales too in Vegas did you
know that no Comedy Cellar
yeah I know they do like celebrity
Jimmy's guys like yeah I'm into this you
really host that that's so funny yeah
they have these like special guest hosts
come for the residency's I just did two
in a row this summer and you know it's
naked would you say do you have to strip
too well I don't have to do anything the
host can just stay but yo what up
everybody whatever but um all the ladies
their money's worth right exactly I was
there now it's like this is kind of
boring so I just like I started to you
can't show I can curse right yes you can
you can't show dick of course but you
can show ass and we wear like these like
socks that cover up our dicks and stuff
so what you do strip down to a dick side
well I take a shower
on stage that's like one of my my thing
so it's like I'm I'm like you see the
back of me and then I turn around I'm
holding it do you feel redid it feel cuz
like I think about how ridiculous and
stupid I was saying what are you saying
you don't do this when you're invited no
he goes to the show it's a great show
we're like taking a sexy shower in front
of people on a stage it's so cool you
love it it's all it's all women right
that are horny and at their bachelorette
parties and it's just like they scream
it's the biggest rush I've ever heard in
my life is it different ages the women
that are there all different but they
have obviously have to be 18 to get
right yeah but I bring in a little bit
more of a younger crowd I think Sharon
Dale's might have traditionally been a
little bit older right now like the
young bachelorette parties coming do you
think the three of us can maybe do
something like that like take sexy
showers onstage for ladies yeah I don't
know
I don't know who's gonna come see that I
think Bobcat Goldthwait on one of those
over the little comic relief I think he
took a shower we should do one two three
with the three pigs tonight Jersey Shore
they came to see me tonight on tonight's
episode bacon might but my cast came to
see me my mom came to see me oh boy my
mom was hysterical crying and it looks
like she's probably crying out of shame
right but she's actually proud like I
don't know it's actually embarrassing
she's too proud that I'm a stripper but
when you're in the room it's like they
play this like it's like a crazy
energetic room that you have this like
big video of me and she was just like
proud that like girls were screaming for
me and stuff how did they convince you
to do it was it a tough sell or were you
like Chippendales that sounds [ __ ]
great
well everybody started laughing at first
and then I was like guys like cuz I
thought it would ever II one thinks it's
a strip club
like a male strip club we did they just
sling in sausage around in people's
faces but it's not like that you know I
went to check out the show those porno
videos with the guy in the bear mask
putting whipped cream on it those are
them
Massabesic a female naked man or some
yeah dancing bad they really are why do
we like that because it's because it
seems like they're real people yeah cuz
they dream real that's like it's like
these video do cfnm sense for male nude
male and it's a dude and dancing bears
are big ones so half the time they're in
a bear mask but it's like a male
stripper and they're walking around in
this room full of women party that are
fully clothed and they put whipped cream
on their dick and they just go girl the
girl and the girls like lick the whipped
cream off and then you wait for the one
that gets like so these are hurried away
these are videos from I mean you know
they're professional not pros but you
know you're sent you wait you wait for
the one look at you in your mind you
don't believe that they're pros at the
moment and so you wait for the one
that's like now you're just blowing him
and you're like oh you dirty thing you
weren't supposed to do that husbands at
home yeah are you gonna ruin this for us
now are they no no I'm gonna enhance it
for you because it's good because it's
the only one that's actually believable
because there are it is production
they're paying everybody probably to be
there that your sign releases whatever
but the extras are real extras I'm not
even getting turned on by like the girls
that are actually doing anything right
it's more like these girls that came
because they want to see to just be
there in the background and just like
get paid a hundred dollars to be in the
rear end of this horny Oprah yeah yeah
but not just a live show it's a real
porn but but there's extras that are
there that are important that are not
porn people that are girls that are just
like sitting there you know what you're
a part you're a part of this just
because you want to see it all go down
yes you feel which is basically like
what Chippendales is right in real life
you have you I mean there's no one
blowing anybody but have you hooked up
with anybody after a Chippendale show oh
yeah have you hooked up with anybody
that's like therefore their bachelorette
party uh no like a bride
yeah no I haven't done any bride but
anyway ah maybe kind of makes me feel
weird like a conscious about it but but
but they've said some crazy things to me
because I at the end they like circling
back this is talking about the meet and
greets yeah what I'm used to
they'll sit on build me-80 they'll sit
on my lap and they'll be like what are
you doing later like you know want to
hang out like this is a bride this is
someone's wife Yeah right I think the
last time you were in was when your
uncle was there and you know yep and
also Brooke Shields that's the last time
you were in where have you been in since
then I probably been in with the Jersey
Shore cast and stuff but Whaley that was
like ona yeah yeah Brooke Shields
yeah chol Nina mm-hmm they didn't bring
you guys in for the Jersey Shore cast
what he fought for it but yeah yeah are
you serious yeah so crazy no way but I
think it's amazing that like it's so
funny cuz MTV tried to do kind of read
you the Jersey Jersey Shore with the
like flora Bama kids hmm and it was like
a good show and everything it was
successful I don't know they were like
they're like you know it wasn't just the
concept now you guys all right you guys
are all adults now you guys all have
businesses you guys are all you know
television stars you're not just some
kids from the East Coast that they're
throwing on TV and they still were like
no we just need the original sure people
like you yeah they like you guys yeah
and people and then like you know people
are watching like crazy except now for
the family reunion series to the Jersey
Shore which is new episodes that are
happening now you're on a third season
the original audience is watching
because I'm interested but then kids are
watching too like kids that weren't you
know watching when the Jersey Shore was
on yeah it's the highest rated show on
MTV not MTV on on TV every Thursday like
unless it's there's football on really
yeah highest-rated show that's on but
now it's totally different because it's
follows more of our outside lives right
we still get together but you know it
right now again like tonight's episode
everyone comes to Vegas to see me in
Chippendales we just we went through
Mike's court sentencing yeah I think my
favorite part of the series was when
Ronnie on the Jersey Shore was making
fun of the situation
calling him the incarceration and it was
right before he was right he just got
out and that's gonna be documented as
well so yeah so if you got you know
we're not just kids you put in a house
anymore like you said and we're all
gonna like hook up and you know our
other outside lives now I'm more
interesting than that but you can't
really like just like hook up with
strangers on camera anymore cuz you're
all celebrities yeah it's true it's a
different I mean it's a different time
it is who's not there for the original
cast just Sammy Sammy yep does anyone
still talk to her I was actually really
close with her before this whole reunion
thing started but I don't really speak
to her anymore she has like a serious
she's like getting married downs it's
not why she didn't want to do it
probably she's like real life not like I
wonder she regrets it cuz he's messed up
on money I mean I know some people don't
want to be like celebrities are some
people don't want their I mean private
life is Appeals mmm-hmm and obviously
like you know making money and stuff you
it's hard work and on a reality show you
give up everything yeah personal life
and you know she was in a relationship
on the original one so she'd probably
have to dive back into that but she's in
a better place now so yeah wait I would
have taken the money but wait the guy
who's the guy she was in the
relationship Ronnie stone he's still on
but he's like you know he has a baby
mama a baby like he's he's moved on you
know birth I don't know
may our new boyfriend was like no you're
not doing that yeah I wouldn't want my
with a girlfriend hanging out with her
ex yeah your girl yeah yeah guys you
bang down the shore that'd be hard if I
had a girlfriend doing that for me too
you look really
I put like 10 pounds on I'm really
depressed about it so what do you what
do you not eat so I don't eat any sugar
or grains or like simple carbs so pasta
bread dessert candy all that stuff yes
that's all kinds of rice yes all kinds I
think all right what about quinoa does
that count it count how about pretzel
that means
don't eat don't eat it no no no no you
know if you look at the back of a label
and it says 22 grams of carbohydrates
then you know but what is part of a
complete breakfast
ya know heart healthy fruit no fruit a
little bit of fruit maybe some berries
but the you know if everyone and anyone
thinks they can eat like a bowl of
grapes and oranges and tangerines
because it's fruit and it's healthy
that's not like blueberries yeah I have
a little bit of a banana after I work
out just because my body's like burning
so much but again I can't eat bananas
all day so I saw I had a bowl of Lucky
Charms last night and said on the box
the first ingredient is fiber yeah yeah
that's usually what happens okay good
perfect
what do you eat cuz I've been on a weird
I was on a whole thirty for a while yeah
that's a hard one to stay on because you
like can't eat anything well you just
seem you can eat real food yeah I don't
know you can buy you need my craving for
anything good yeah did you have any
snacks when you were out shooting in
Rhode Island me on some Tuesday here I
literally I was [ __ ] shoveling my
hand into the peanut M&Ms like a big
[ __ ] I've witnessed it I thought he
was exaggerating it before but I've
witnessed it he goes like I can't do
little candies cuz the attic in me comes
out and it's like nothing you've ever
seen before
yeah and I go alright [ __ ] like I'll
have three or four I get it everybody
does that and I watched him we were
doing Bert Kreischer his podcast and
Bert it was like around Halloween and so
he had a bowl of like little fun size
candy bars that's no good and I swear to
God and maybe a minute and a half I
watched norton slam through two dozen is
a drug you know and that's what the
whole point of this diet is is that
we're walking around is trying to get
our fixes all day long and you know we
need those fixes for energy like we
actually need them you know because if
you're running off of sugar you have a
banana and then you get tired again I
need a granola bar then you get tired
again alright now I need a piece of
bread I get tired again
Kido isn't that so Kido you're trading
in the sugar vise for
okay you're substituting one cuz fat is
looked at to be like it's a healthy vice
though but it's a good fats right well
there's been a misconception about what
what good and bad yeah well you know I
mean what would you consider what do you
think a good fat is like avocado what
else now but like when it like a writ
like a grass-fed healthy ribeye uh-huh
like I guess red meat steak french fried
chick right
no well fried chicken but not with the
breadcrumb like roasted chicken with
Justin on yeah so natural anything
natural hundred-percent so you know
flour mmm almond flour bro look in that
book like my desserts my recipes are
crazy but they're like okay yes what
they're substituting fatty nuts are
better but there's my recipes are
substituting you know a regular flour
for almond flour so it's like eating the
same things you want but you don't have
that like disgusting like creators
feeling no next question see a whole
thirty started allowing potatoes just do
they weren't they were natural right
well they're they're they're natural I
think it's on corn assert more that's
sugar yeah corn and sugar okay yeah next
question this one is how often do you
eat all right that's a good question and
then I also know then like the late at
night good question good question okay
okay so yeah question now you gotta get
got to give you a book so what you eat
and when you eat is is how you sustain a
way of life where you'll always be thin
okay
so basically I do something called
intermittent fasting right that pairs up
with this diet there's at eight hours of
and then you can pick your window
whenever you want what do you do
are you doing between like 12 and 812
between 12 p.m. and 8:00 I'm sorry yeah
12 p.m. and 8 p.m. so you do eight hours
that's when you eat 16 off yes you don't
fast day-by-day you fat
you eat everyday yeah I eat every day
some people look like a whole 24:16 on
an date or you could do like I've been
having these signings so might there I
get out late so I had to shift it to
between 2:00 p.m. and 10:00 p.m. so you
could just shift your window charmer you
go to bed though like last night I went
to bed um like out like 12:00 something
Sokka you want to have a couple hours
before Yeah right before and after but
within that eight hour window how often
do you eat honestly like I'm uh I'm a
foodie right right so I love having like
big fatty good meals so I'd rather
sacrifice and not eat like constantly
okay I just have like my big dinner
you know what I mean so I'll have like
eggs and bacon that'll be like my first
meal and then have an iced coffee and
then next thing you know it's like
dinner time and like yeah six seven
o'clock and now I'm having like
vegetables and a big steak or I'm
ordering barbecue without cheese there's
no cheese on barbecue sauce so I have to
tell everybody to not put sauce on my
[ __ ] and I hate that I hate sauce anyway
like ruins a taste of everything right
and then you go out like I went to this
like fancy steak house somewhere and
like they had I got meat cellar and like
it smelled like smoked everything and I
was like oh this is gonna be so good and
then they gave me it was literally
drowning in barbecue sauce like always
feel like the more sauce people put on
the shittier than meat is shitty right
cuz they're trying to disguise yeah
never go down south there's no sauce
right it's a little bit of dry rub that
cooks into it and then that's it I'm a
big sauce on the side guy for anyone
who's interested what Jim you love to
dip yeah yeah I do
Jim is a Dipper yeah but Jim so if you
can do like eggs and bacon did you like
that or not I do but the bacon bot I got
I want to eat too much meat I'm careful
about the meat intake on your personal
life that's all I do
slap it and join laughing yeah Jim's on
a high-protein diet a nice dating life
no but I try to you know I try to not
eat as much but I lay I like bacon
vegetables okay like health reasons or
yeah just for health so now like it hard
so obviously for your heart I
try to eat yeah because we were talking
we were taught that you know again I'm
not a scientist and it's a whole other
thing but we were taught that fat
cholesterol high fat that's bad for you
and we should eat grains instead okay
yes so again this is the opposite this
is eating fatty bacon ribeyes everything
that we were taught not to believe eat
that butter and don't eat the processed
sugar and carbs that we have and when
you do that if you do both together
you're gonna be unhealthy but when you
like completely X out the sugar the
process then and then you have the other
one like all your blood levels
everything like resets and becomes
health my cholesterol is fine because I
don't do the other thing but it's so
funny that we don't flinch at eating the
giant thing of M&Ms but he's like I
can't have too much I know the M&M is a
bad deal like I'm eating them and I'm
like you [ __ ] pig but the media and
ever the world has not conditioned you
to be like that's gonna kill you kill
you right like it's you know it's bad
but it's like the bacon part you're like
I can't eat this I'm gonna died like
have a heart attack tomorrow yeah III
eat it I just tryin to eat it every like
I tried to even meat if every day I
leave it that is true like when I'm
eating sugar it's like as long as my
titties don't get too big and the
doctors you're fine but with with the
bacon and the greasy stuff you go oh no
I bet my arteries are clogging up that's
what scares me yeah I know it's time to
stop eating if a baby cries and milk
comes out of my teeth I would like to
have this book I can't cook but I want
to start cooking I mean you would like
that you have it it's right there this
pizza is my favorite right here so the
pizza is made of the crust I don't like
cauliflower okay so the crust is a a
cheese almond flour base so just enough
to hold it together you have a nice
texture and then on top I put Regatta
cheese prosciutto and truffle oil how
did you learn how to cook did you learn
to cook when you were a kid from your
mom or did yeah I learned I learned from
my mom but what happened was like five
years ago when I
started to eat like this ya can't eat
like this in a restaurant or anywhere
else so I would go on YouTube and I'd be
like alright I want chicken cutlets but
how do I make the healthy version of
chicken cutlets almond chicken cutlets I
found it I'm in chicken cutlets so I
would like learn how to do it but then
I'd call my mom and my mom would be like
she's like a cook so we would like like
online is like the white people versions
and we were like yeah gaining it up you
know what I mean so that's kind of what
the book is now I would you if somebody
came to you and said Oh Vinny I like
your new book the keto guide oh would
you consider them to be an idiot
I would forgive them yeah there would be
idiots they would be a TNC ok so Rob
there's a question right but it is kind
of like a guide you know just really
white what is less named Sirocco so I
don't know why yeah he's a disgrace
disgrace to the gender and the
nationality vegetables all good greens
greens I'm gonna carrot how about a
carrot how about orange I can't have a
carrot yeah nice
some people they know the people well
you know what's funny like the the
people that are like really really Kido
cuz it's about macros you know what
macros are so macros are like the
percentage of like a pie chart of how
much fat to carbohydrates to protein
you're eating so on a keto diet
it's a 75% fat diet then a slight sliver
of a moderate amount of protein and then
like a 10 percent carbs okay so if you
go over that with the tomatoes and
everything then like you're out of those
macros so you wanted this have like a
little bit you know gotcha
one more gemandsam
catch-up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app